hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and i've bought
hundreds of houses and in this video i'm
going to explain to you the exact
process of actually buying a house
what happens
start to finish so step one when you're
buying a house is you're gonna need to
start by having a goal in mind and
knowing
what are you buying a house for so this
is actually really important i know
having a goal might sound really basic
and motivational it's not every
solicitor agent broker they're going to
ask you these questions they're going to
say number one are you buying it as a
residential or buy to let and you need
to know the difference residential means
you're buying it to live in the house
yourself
buy to let means you're buying it to
rent it out so you need to know which
one you're doing and it's important that
you don't mix this up the process is the
same you also need to know how you're
going to be financing this property is
this going to be cash or mortgages will
everybody say to you and you'll need to
know how you're going to finance it are
you going to be buying this cash
or are you going to be buying it
mortgage so that's the first thing to
just understand about what are you
buying this for what's the goal how are
you going to be financing it
step two get a solicitor
now you might wonder at what point
should i find a solicitor do i have to
wait until i've already found a house do
i have no
it's step two okay step two is find a
solicitor a conveyancing solicitor
namely a solicitor that deals with
property transactions and ask them hey
i'm looking at buying a house can i put
your name down as my solicitor now this
could be a recommended solicitor this
could be somebody that you know from
your network it could be someone you
found from google but you need a
solicitor now you can change solicitor
at any time so if it's listed as your
head in and you decide actually i don't
want to use them you can change the
solicitor but step two is you need a
solicitor in place before you start
doing anything step three
mortgage broker
do not try and get a mortgage from your
bank because if you go to your bank and
you say oh can i get a mortgage blues
they might decline you at worst or at
best they will offer you the mortgage
that they can offer you you want to go
to an independent mortgage broker
this is step three and the independent
mortgage broker will look at all the
lenders all the banks and they will give
you the best
lender the best mortgage for you and for
the house that you are buying now you
might think it's too early to be
speaking to mortgage brokers it's not
if you're planning on buying a house
step one is have a goal and know what
kind of house you're going to be buying
because that's what the solicitor and
mortgage broker are going to ask but st
step step two is step three speak to a
broker and say i'm thinking of buying a
house
could i get a mortgage can we have a
conversation and then what they'll do is
they'll check your credit they'll have
an initial consultation they shouldn't
charge you any money for this neither
should the solicitor you're not paying
you're just lining up your team so that
when you start viewing houses you've got
this ready in place step four
funds
no mortgage broker no bank will lend you
100 of the money to go and buy a house
so if you're buying a house if it's a
residential house you can borrow up to
95 as a mortgage that's max
that's the first time buyers
if it's a buy to let
you can borrow typically 75
of the purchase price on the house that
leaves you with a shortfall right so
you're gonna have to the little bit
you'll have to top up what's that called
that's called a deposit so you're gonna
have to step four
know where your actual deposit is gonna
come from is it gonna come from if it's
a gift from a family member that's okay
because brokers are happy lenders are
happy
for for you to top the difference up the
deposit from a gift if it's a loan from
a bank
they're going to be uncomfortable
because they're going to say you you've
got no skin in the game so you need to
speak to your mortgage broker and you
need to work out where's this money
coming from the first question a broker
is going to ask you is they're going to
say how much money have you got right
now what's your deposit going to be and
then they can find you the difference in
form of a mortgage step 5 you're going
to have to actually find a house right
and it might be that you don't even
start looking for houses probably you
shouldn't until you've done step one
step two step three and step four if you
if you're viewing houses and the estate
agents are saying to you
so where's your deposit coming from
who's your mortgage broker have you got
a sister lined up and you go no i'm just
viewing the house for fun
that's okay that's no problem but the
estate agent will not take you as
serious and if you're serious about
buying a house really you want to do
these steps in the order that i'm saying
it's going to really help you out so
five is actually find a house how do you
find a house well i do
a lot of training programs and help a
lot of people on how to find the best
houses in the right areas for the right
price and how to negotiate but this
video is about the big picture of buying
a house so maybe you could find houses
on rightmove maybe you could go into an
estate agent and just say this is what
i'm looking for when you speak to estate
agents what they're going to want to
know is they're going to want to get
your details if you ring an estate agent
now and say i'm looking to buy a house
they'll say no problem what's your name
what's your address what's your phone
number what's your email what are you
looking for we'll put you on our list
that is what an estate agent will say
when you phone them up let them ring us
their agents and tell them yeah man put
me on your list and then tell them
exactly what you are looking for before
step six step six is
the viewing
no estate agent in the country will let
you put an offer on a house or buy a
house unless first you have viewed the
house or
there are some the whole there's
exceptions to everything okay you can
pay someone to view the house for you
you can get a deal saucer but generally
speaking
you have to and should view the house
before buying it or putting an offer on
it so step six is you're gonna go around
you're gonna look at the house you're
gonna do your research you're gonna see
if it ticks all the boxes
for your investment or residential
purposes that is step six step seven is
putting an offer forward on the house
now sometimes people really wonder you
know how do you put forward an offer do
you have to write a letter
do you have to send an email
how does it work and how do you know how
much to put forward
let me explain real simple putting an
offer forward on the house literally
goes like this
hey i'd like to put an offer on the
house like you just ring up
and you tell them what you're wanting to
offer now again i run hours of training
on how to negotiate the best prices and
how to get a really good offer but what
i'll say right now is never offer full
asking price you're going to want to get
a discount so put forward your offer and
the estate agent will
do a bit of backing and forwarding with
you so they'll say oh let me put it to
the seller
there will be the in between never try
and go direct to the seller because the
agent will hate you for it and the
estate agent needs to be your best
friend so you're going to let the estate
agent do all the negotiations you're
going to tell them what you want to
offer and then hopefully you will soon
hear the good news of congratulations
your offer has been accepted which
brings you to the next step
getting the memorandum of sale what does
this mean the memorandum of sale is a
document a one-page document that the
estate agent will give you which is when
your offer has been fully accepted it's
agreed you've got a little piece of
paper that says congrats and it's all
going ahead now you're not going to be
able to get this document by simply the
seller saying offer accepted
once your offer has been accepted in
order to get this piece of paper from
the agent you're going to need to
provide some proof of who the heck you
are they're not going to give you a
memorandum of sale to some stranger
they're going to want to know they're
going to want to see some form of
identification they're going to want a
correspondence address they're going to
want your solicitor details at this
point you've paid zero money to your
solicitor
you've found a solicitor marked a
solicitor and you've given the details
of the solicitor over to the estate
agent in order to get your memorandum of
understanding you're going to provide
your mortgage brokers details
they're going to want something called a
mortgage dip a dip means a decision in
principle so as soon as your offer has
been accepted you're gonna have to go
back to your broker and you'll say to
your mortgage broker
great news this is the exact property
this is now they're gonna want to see a
decision in principle the mortgage
broker in question might take a few days
to get this decision in principle so
they may give you the uh memorandum of
sale without a dip but just with
confirmation from the mortgage broker
that you're good but they're gonna want
your mortgage brokers details and lastly
number five
is they're gonna wanna see of course
your proof of funds those are the five
things that they're gonna need to see
from you before issuing you with that
beautiful memorandum of sale which leads
you onto step eight the sales
progression the sales progression
typically takes about three months you
might think why don't houses just
complete quickly i want to buy it
the seller wants to sell it i've got the
money what's the hold up well there is a
hold up and that is namely solicitors
having to do things called searches what
are searches searches are the solicitor
dealing and liaising with the sellers
solicitor because to buy a house you
need a solicitor by law and the seller
needs this listed by law so your sister
and the seller solicitor are going to
have a bit of a thrashing out job where
they're going to go over every single
little detail of the house down to the
water the drainage um who owns what
legally who owns this fence compared to
that fence so there's a whole bunch of
stuff that the splisters are going to
thrash out they're also going to need to
do things like check the title deeds
make sure the property is not got any
mine shafts under it make sure that the
person who says they're selling the
property actually owns the title deeds
this can take time because solicitors
tend to be pretty slow meanwhile while
the solicitor is going through all these
searches you are using your mortgage
broker to actually get the money for the
purchase so your mortgage broker is
going to be relentlessly working to find
the best mortgage for you get you an
official mortgage offer and this will be
running alongside the solicitor doing
the searches this is all called the
sales progression the most valuable
piece of advice i can give you
is during the sales progression you want
everybody to be working together
communication is key your mortgage
broker your solicitor and the estate
agent should all be in communication and
should be talking and you as the actual
buyer of the property should do two
things number one
when the ball is in your court what do i
mean by that i mean if they've given you
something to sign if the solicitor said
that they need to jump on a quick call
with you to check that it's really you
and they need to see you face to face on
facetime for 30 seconds don't delay it
get the ball out of your
court as quick as you can otherwise
you're going to hold things up and
you're going to frustrate the seller
however when the ball is not in your
court
yes you can chase your team a little bit
but you need to be patient because it
does take time and if you're on the
phone every day at your sister chasing
them chasing them chasing them you're
probably going to be a nightmare client
and they might not want to do business
with you again so when the balls in your
court knock it out and when it's not in
your court be patient
the solicitor and the mortgage broker if
you're in communication with everybody
they will guide you through the sales
progression and tell you exactly what
you need to do in order to complete
safely ethically and legally
get an independent building survey on
your property this is not a legal
requirement but it is something that i
would highly recommend and what this
means is you're going to get a building
survey on the property they're going to
check the property with a fine tooth
comb they're going to check the roof
they're going to check the
structural aspect of the property
make sure that the property is in good
condition now you may say i don't need
to get a survey because my mortgage
company are coming out to survey the
property anyway yes they will before
they give you money for the property
they will come and look at the property
but they'll spend 15 minutes in the
house just checking that it looks okay
you may say my solicitors are going to
do searches and they're going to make
sure the property is okay and it's
freehold and it's in good standing yes
they are because that's their legal
that's their legal responsibility but
you need to get an independent building
survey that will come in they'll spend a
few hours in the property it's not a
legal requirement but you do not want to
buy a house if there's a problem that
has been missed by the mortgage lender
or the solicitors
it costs about 350 pounds and if you
speak to your mortgage broker and you
tell them you want a survey the mortgage
broker will probably be able to
recommend a surveyor to you but just get
an independent building survey and what
that means is if there's a real issue
the independent building surveyor will
be liable they are responsible for
making sure that they tell you that the
property is in good standing it's one of
the most best
400 pounds you can ever spend exchange
and completion so you're going to
exchange contracts
and then you're going to complete
contracts the difference between
exchanging and completing contracts just
means when you exchange contracts that's
when you've both signed and the
contracts are exchanged completion is
when you actually get
the solicitor register the title deeds
you pay and you don't need to actually
pay for the property until you complete
so during those three or four months of
sales progression
that's you're not going to need to pay
for anything apart from the fees of the
professionals so that is the 10 steps to
buying a house i hope you found it
helpful and i look forward to seeing you
guys next time don't forget to subscribe
to the channel if you enjoy my property
investment videos and also hit like see
you soon